Google just dropped NanoBanana 2. This is
by far the best image generator and editor
we have right now. This is way faster than
the previous version, NanoBanana Pro. Plus,
they claim it has much better world understanding,
consistency, and prompt adherence. So,
in this video, I'm going to go over all the crazy
things that you can do with it, and I'm going to
compare this with the previous version of Nano
Banana. Plus, I'm going to go over its specs and
performance benchmarks and where you can use it
for free. Let's jump right in. Now, before I start
showing you some demos, it's worth mentioning
that we already have a ton of image models that
can do simple stuff like colorizing and restoring
old photos or removing watermarks or changing the
camera angle of a photo or changing the pose of
someone, doing close swapping and all that fun
stuff. This is already really easy to do and all
the top models can ace these tests already. So,
in this video, I'm mainly going to show you some
extremely challenging prompts to really test the
limits of Nano Banano 2. All right. Now, one of
the main advantages of Nano Banana is it has such
a good world understanding of pretty much any
famous celebrity or existing character in the
world. We can prompt it to make a photo of a ton
of celebrities all in the same shot. For example,
here I have Johnny Depp, Jackie Chan, Taylor
Swift, Tom Hanks, The Rock, Michael Jackson,
Oprah, Blackpink, Cristiano Ronaldo, Elon Musk,
Beyonce, Leonardo, Raana, Brad Pitt, Selena Gomez,
Will Smith, Lady Gaga, Justin Bieber, Barack
Obama, and Ariana taking a group selfie. And
here is what we got from Nano Banana 2. You can
see all the characters are actually present,
and they do look like the actual celebrity. Now,
because there's so many characters jam-packed into
this one shot, the resolution isn't great. So,
you can see like some noise in the facial details
of some of these characters, but overall,
it's not bad. And then for your reference,
here is the generation from Nano Banana Pro. You
can see the photo isn't really as coherent. Plus,
it messed up Black Pink. That looks
really weird. Anyways, as you can see,
in terms of just the realism and coherence of
the photo, this generation from the new Nano
Banana looks much better than Nano Banana Pro,
which kind of looks like they're all just glued
together. This doesn't look very realistic. Now,
in addition to realistic people, this also has an
extremely good world knowledge of cartoon, anime,
and 2D characters. So for example here we have
Levi Acriman Ana Forger Rick and Morty Gohan Alons
Chica Fujiada Emmelia Gojo Nzuko Curto Kenny Bart
Simpson and Snow White taking a selfie. Notice
that these are from a ton of different anime
shows and American cartoons Disney characters.
And some of these aren't even like the main
characters. These are just secondary characters.
But as you can see for both Nano Banana models,
they were able to understand and generate all
of these characters really well. So, first let's
inspect Nano Banana 2. I can't really spot any
errors with this. It can generate everyone very
well. And it looks like it put them in some anime
expo 2024. Pretty cool. It even got the fingers
correct. So, you can see that actually Kenny
and Bart Simpson only has four fingers, which
is what they actually have in the real cartoon.
And then here we have Nano Banana Pro. And again,
it got pretty much all the characters correct. I
can't really spot any flaws with this. So overall,
I would say it's a pass and a tie between both
models. All right, next. Here's a test on how good
it is at generating tricky expressions. This still
trips up even the top image generators out there.
So here we have a 4x4 grid of a young female with
these emotions. From left to right, top to bottom,
we have happiness, awe, enthusiasm, confidence,
sadness, jealousy, irritation, embarrassment,
surprise, confusion, nostalgia, fear, love,
relief, pride, and anticipation. So let's
review Nano Banana 2 first. She does look happy.
This does look awe. The first row looks very good.
She does look like each of these emotions. Even
the confidence one, which is pretty tricky. It
rendered this very well. And then for the second
row, we have sadness, jealousy, irritation,
embarrassment. And even for these three, jealousy,
irritation, and embarrassment. It also rendered
these very well. And then for the third row,
we have surprise, confusion, nostalgia, and
fear. It's also really good. Like she does look
confused here. And this does look like nostalgia.
And then for the last row, we have love, relief,
pride, and anticipation. For love, I'm not sure
if this really looks like love. Let me know in
the comments below. This one looks really good.
She does look relieved. And I guess this does look
like pride. Anticipation looks very good. And then
here we have the previous Nano Banana Pro. So for
the first row, it's very good. Here's the second
row. Jealousy looks kind of weird. I wouldn't say
it's as good as Nano Banana 2. For the third row,
all of these look pretty good. And then here's
the last row for love and pride. Let me know in
the comments if this actually looks like love
and pride to you. For relief, this does look
pretty accurate. And then same with anticipation.
So overall, both of them are decent. But if I had
to pick a winner, I would have to go for Nano
Banana 2. It looks just slightly more realistic
for some expressions, especially for jealousy and
awe. All right, here's an even trickier test. I
got it to make a 4x4 grid featuring Pokémon with
these Pokédex numbers. And here's what I got. Now,
interestingly, even though I got it to make a
4x4 grid, Nanobanana Pro kind of hallucinated
and gave me a 3x5 grid instead. So, it messed
this up pretty badly. But anyways, let's go
over Nano Banana 2 first. So, 07 is Squirtle and
then 18 is Pidgeot. These are all correct and they
also look correct. And then for the second row,
these are also correct. Now, for the third row,
2011 is really tricky because this is unknown. So
there's actually an unknown for each letter of the
alphabet. Here it says the label is unknown A. But
if I Google what unknown A looks like, it should
look like this. So this one is actually wrong.
Again, this is a really tricky prompt. I don't
expect it to get it 100% correct. And then for
the last row, we also have an error for this one,
Cascoon, which should actually look like this.
So Nano Banana 2 completely messed this up. So
it got two out of the 16 wrong. Now, the previous
Nano Banana Pro didn't do too well either. So,
again, it hallucinated and gave me a 3x5 grid.
So, it has repeats here like gold duck and
[__] apparently. So, this is completely wrong.
And then it also added this extra grimer here,
which is really weird. And then for unknown, let
me just double check if there is an unknown with
this shape. And it doesn't look like anything
in this diagram. I was expecting it to be a K
or an F, but this looks slightly off. So that's
also a fail. However, it did get Cascoon correct
over here. So I don't know. I would say it's a
tie between these two models. Both of them were
not able to get unknown correct. The new Nano
Banana 2 wasn't able to get Cascoon correct,
but it was able to follow my 4x4 grid instruction
in the prompt. Whereas for Nano Banana Pro,
it did not give me a 4x4 grid, but it got casc. So
there's pros and cons to each. All right, here's
another cool test on its world understanding.
Here I got to make a highresolution where's Waldo
image. It should be very complex and filled with
meme characters. Waldo should be hidden somewhere
in the image. So here's what we got from Nano
Banana 2. You can see a ton of meme characters in
this image, including this rainbow cat plus Doge
over here. Meme coins, plus all these different
meme characters. This is really cool. And it
did insert Waldo in the photo, although he isn't
really hidden. And then I guess we have an extra
Waldo clone here, which isn't really correct,
but anyways, that is Nano Banana 2. You can see
that it has a really good world understanding
of all these meme characters. And then here's
what we got from Nano Banana Pro. Also really
impressive. And it did insert Waldo somewhere
in the image. So I would say both of these
are okay. But in terms of the quality and how
similar it is to an actual Where's Waldo image,
I would have to give the point to Nano Banana Pro.
This looks a lot more detailed and complex and it
resembles a Where's Waldo image a lot more. Let
me know in the comments what you think. All right,
here's another really tricky prompt, which
I don't expect it to get 100% correct. So,
here's a grid of the six most endangered frogs in
the world with their scientific name and a short
description at the bottom of each photo. So, here
is what I got from Nano Banana 2. The first one
it gave me is a mountain chicken frog. I have not
heard of this frog. This looks super normal to me,
but let me just Google its scientific name
really quickly. And would you look at that?
There is a leptodactylus phallax frog and it
is called the mountain chicken frog and it is
critically endangered and it does look like this.
And then next up we have this Panameanian golden
frog. Let me again Google this really quickly. And
here's our result. It does look like this. It is
called the Panameanian golden frog. And this is
critically endangered and possibly extinct in the
wild, which is very sad. But there you go. This
is also correct. Now, next one, we have this ticky
kaka water frog, which looks like Oh my god, what
is it doing? Anyways, it should look something
like this, I guess. Now, this is endangered. It's
not critically endangered. I'm not sure if it's
like part of the top 10 most endangered frogs
out there. I would say the photo doesn't look
exactly like the real thing. And then next we have
this golden Mantela frog which indeed exists and
pretty cool. It has a golden form and a red form.
It has an extremely restricted distribution and
so here it lists it as endangered. So apparently
it's only found in this tiny part of Madagascar.
Pretty crazy. So this does look correct. And
then we have Archie's frog from New Zealand.
And here's what it looks like in real life. And
this is critically endangered. So, I guess going
back to this photo from Nanopanana, it looks kind
of similar to the real thing. I wouldn't say it's
like 100% correct. And then finally, we have this
Kihanzi spray toad, which looks like this. And
this is extinct in the wild. Very sad. Again, I
wouldn't say this looks like the real thing. Here
are some additional photos. The real frog looks a
lot more yellow. So, I would say it got like the
descriptions and the names correct, but in terms
of the photos, it's not that good. And I don't
expect it to get this correct. This is a really
tricky prompt because an AI model needs a lot
of existing data to know and generate that thing.
But if we have these critically endangered species
with only a few photos, then it's really hard for
an AI to actually understand and generate this
from scratch. Anyways, here is the generation from
NanoPanana Pro. And interestingly, it gave me like
four different frogs compared to the generation
from Nano Banana 2. So, this panameanian golden
frog we've gone over before. And then we have this
cycinillaa Andes frog which apparently is so rare
that there's not even any information about this.
And then we have this midwife toad which looks
like this and this is endangered and it's only
found in small parts of this tiny island somewhere
in the world. Now I wouldn't say this image looks
exactly like the real thing. So this is wrong. And
then we have this Alcatraz snouted tree frog which
is critically endangered and it looks something
like this. I would say it's pretty close. And then
this one we've gone over already. And then we have
this Hamilton's frog which looks like this.
And apparently this is vulnerable globally but
nationally critical. And it's only found in like
these small islands in New Zealand. Pretty crazy.
Now it looks something like this. So again, it's
not like entirely correct, but it's pretty close.
Anyways, it's a tough call here. Let me know in
the comments which one you prefer. Now the awesome
thing about Nano Banana Pro is you can upload
multiple images and get it to edit those images.
So here I'm testing to see if it can help me do
homework. Here, I'm going to upload this worksheet
of an animal cell. And for the prompt, I got to
fill in the blanks and use messy handwriting so
it looks like I actually did it. So, here's what I
got from both models. Here's Nano Banana 2. And as
you can see, it can get some stuff correct, but
not all of them. So, for example, mitochondri.
And then cell membrane, it also got correct.
Same with cytoplasm, GG apparatus, and then
rough endopplasmic reticulum, it also got correct.
However, it also labeled some of them completely
wrong. So, for example, this one here should be
the nucleus, not the nucleololis. And then this
one here should be the nucleololis, not the rough
ER. And then here's what I got from the previous
Nano Banana Pro. And I would say it got even more
stuff wrong. So, for example, here it labeled the
cell membrane to be the nucleololis, which is just
absolutely horrible. And then here, this should
be the cytoplasm, but it labeled it the cell
membrane. In terms of having the fewest errors, I
would say Nano Banana 2 did a better job. However,
note that for some strange reason, it turned this
into like a photo copy. This looks like a photo
of this worksheet, whereas for Nano Banana Pro,
it retained the original white background. All
right, maybe biology was too hard for it. So,
here I uploaded this math assignment and also got
it to solve these problems with messy handwriting.
And here's what I got from Nano Banana 2. You can
see it does look like I wrote this. It even added
this part over here as if I cross this out to
make this look more natural. Pretty sneaky. And
then here is Nano Banana Pro's generation. This
is also really good. This also does look like the
answers are handwritten. However, it got a lot
more errors with this generation. For example,
here it repeated this divide by 4.8 twice, which
is not correct. We only need one line. And then
over here, this is also wrong. Whereas you can
see for Nanoban 2, it's actually able to show my
work a lot more correctly. So, in this instance,
I would have to give the points to Nano Banana
2. I've been covering the best image and video
generators, and it can get very overwhelming.
Fortunately, Higsfield, the sponsor of this video,
brings everything together all in one place. You
can use the best image and video models all in one
integrated platform. They're usually the first to
release models when they come out, and Nano Banana
2 is already available on their platform. Simply
click on image and then Nanobanana 2 to start
creating. And they just launched Higsfield Soul 2,
their own foundation image model built
specifically for creative, fashionware,
culture native image generation. This isn't
just a general purpose image generator. Soul
2 is designed to give you aesthetically awesome
images. Let me show you how this actually works.
So inside Higsfield under image, simply click
on soul 2. And here you can just enter a text
prompt and then also select the aspect ratio
and the resolution. Or if you want more control,
Soul Reference lets you upload an image and
generate new variations that feel like they
belong to the same visual world. And it doesn't
stop there. Because Soul 2.0 is built to be the
foundation of your creative process, it pairs
really well with other tools inside Higsfield
like Nano Banana Pro. The idea is simple. Generate
your image in Soul 2.0 first. Nail the lighting,
composition, and aesthetic, and then bring it
into Nano Banana Pro for editing. The stronger
your bass, the better everything downstream looks.
Sold 2.0 currently comes with 20 curated presets,
things like Y2K, editorial, street style, old
smartphone, and more. These are fully trained
aesthetic directions that act as creative starting
points. It understands fashion culture, camera
mediums, and even posing. You get more natural
body language, better physics, and editorial
quality results. Try Nano Banana 2, Soul 2.0, know
and other top models on Higsfield today. Click
the link in the description below. All right,
here's an even harder test. So, I uploaded this
image and I got it to put this image into four
quadrants. For the first quadrant, it needs to
be an infrared thermal map of the photo. For the
second quadrant, it should be a segmentation map
of the photo. For the third quadrant, it should
be a depth map. And for the fourth quadrant,
the photo should have inverted colors. So, first
of all, here's what I got from Nano Banana 2. For
this infrared map, it's actually pretty good.
So indeed her skin should be warmer than for
example her dress plus this sofa. But she should
also be emitting heat. So like parts of the sofa
where she's touching should be more yellow which
is indeed correct. I'm not sure why it's making
her eyes and then her knees here white though. So
the white part is an error for the windows in the
background. They should be a lot cooler and that's
why these are darker in color. So the infrared map
is like 80% correct. Here is the segmentation map.
This is pretty good. Here's the depth map. This
also looks pretty good. And then here is the
inverted pictures. So if I invert the colors,
while this is close, these aren't the original
colors of the photo, which should look like this.
So again, not entirely correct here. And then here
is Nano Banana Pro's generation. For the heat map,
it's pretty good. However, one slight error here
is that maybe the dress should actually be lighter
in color. So in that case, I would have to give
the point more to Nano Banana 2. And then here's
the segmentation map. Here's the depth map. And
then here is the inversion. Let me invert the
colors again. And here is the original photos.
So again, not entirely correct here. Anyways,
this is a really tricky prompt. Let me know in the
comments which one you prefer. All right. Next,
here's a tricky prompt that no image generator has
gotten correct so far. So, the prompt is 11:15 on
a clock and a wine glass filled to the top. For
Nano Banana 2, it's not really clear which hand is
the minute hand and which is the hour hand. So, I
mean, at least to me, this one looks shorter. So,
it's like showing 255 instead of 11:15. And then
the wine glass is also not filled to the top. Very
disappointing. And then here is Nano Banana Pro.
The wine glass is filled to the top. However, it
failed to generate 11:15. It was very close, but
the hourhand should be a quarter past 11 and not
exactly at 11. So, both are not good, but in terms
of the least amount of errors, I would have to
give the point to NanoBanana Pro. All right. Next,
I uploaded this manga page and got it to colorize
and translate this to Chinese. So, here's what I
got from Nano Banana 2. The Chinese looks perfect,
and the colorization is also really good. It's
also able to detect that this dude is called Red
Hair Shanks and then color this guy's hair red.
And then here is Nano Banana Pro. It also got
the Chinese and the coloration correct. But you
know, an interesting difference here is that for
Nano Banana 2, it decided to translate this into
traditional Chinese, whereas for the Pro version,
it translated it into simplified Chinese. Very
interesting. All right. Next, here's a test on
its spatial understanding. So, I uploaded this
floor plan, and here's my prompt. Based on this
floor plan, generate a photo of this room from the
main door. So, not only does it need to analyze
the spatial configuration of this room, but it
also needs to understand where the main door is,
which is over here, and generate a photo from
this corner. Now, here's what I got from Nano
Banana 2. Unfortunately, this is not correct.
There are some errors with this. For example,
the bathroom should be in this corner and not
over here. And then there should be sofas and
plants over here in the foreground instead of
on this left wall. The piano is also facing the
wrong direction. It should be facing the lower
right corner instead. So, a lot of errors with
this generation. It does not look like the floor
plans configuration at all. And then here is Nano
Banana Pros generation. It was able to get the
configuration of things more correct, but this
wasn't a photo of the room from the main door over
here. So, ideally, I would wanted to make a photo
of this room taken from this corner. However,
it did get more details correct. For example,
the round bed plus the piano should be facing the
lower right corner. Plus, the sofas and plants
here are also correct according to this original
floor plan. So, in terms of having fewer errors,
I would have to give the point to Nano Banana
Pro. Now, here's a test on the reverse. Here,
I got to make a 2D floor plan of this room. And
then I uploaded this image. Here's what I got from
Nano Banana 2 and everything looks pretty good.
the configurations of the plants and the sofas
plus the TV screen. Everything looked correct
to me. Now, interestingly, for Nano Banana Pro,
this one had more errors. For example, it added
two additional sofas here which did not exist
in the original photo. Plus, the plants in the
foreground are also not correct. So, here I would
have to give the point to Nano Banana 2. Now, Nano
Banana is also extremely good in converting data
tables into charts. So, for example, I can just
upload this data table and then prompt it to turn
it into a nice chart. You can decide the best type
of chart to use. And here's what I got from Nano
Banana 2. And the numbers are actually correct.
So, if I compare like the first two bars here,
the total sample size is 88, which is
correct. And then we have 5 50 28 2 and 3,
which is what we have here. And then for
this RR percent, it's 62.5, which is correct.
And then for fullf fox the sample size is 52 which
is correct. Then we have 2 26 212 and 1 which are
correct over here. And then we have 53.8 which is
the RR percent which is correct. It even added a
nice legend at the bottom plus some nice styling
for this chart. However, if you look at the third
row then here is where it starts to fall apart.
So here the sample size is 7 which is correct but
then it should be 2 3 1 0 1. However, as you can
see here, the size of these bars are way too tall.
So, this should be way smaller in size. Now, if
you compare this same bar with Nano Banana Pro,
it actually got this correct. So, indeed, it
should be 2 3 1 and 1. So, this is actually a lot
better than Nano Banana 2. In terms of accuracy
and the least amount of errors in this instance,
I would have to give the points to Nano Banana
Pro. All right, so that sums up my series of
really challenging tests. Hopefully that gives you
a sense of the strengths and weaknesses of Nano
Banana 2 and how it compares with the previous
version. Here are some additional examples from
Google. Here we can get it to generate a flat lay
infographic depicting the water cycle and it's
able to generate this pretty much flawlessly. With
both models of Nano Banana, you can input multiple
reference images. So here they're inputting like
14 reference images into the same photo and it's
able to generate this very well. You can of course
also use Nano Banana to crop or outpaint or change
the aspect ratio of an existing photo. Next, let's
go over the specs of Nano Banana 2 and why this is
so good. First of all, note that Nano Banana 2
is based off of Gemini 3.1 Flash, whereas Nano
Banana Pro, the previous version, was based off
of Gemini 3 Pro. There's pros and cons of each,
right? For this one, it's the latest 3.1, which is
better than 3.0, but it's also flash and not pro.
So this is more designed for speed whereas the
pro version is designed for quality. Now if you've
been using Nano Banana Pro then definitely one
of the main disadvantages is you have to wait a
long time for it to generate an image. Whereas for
this new Nano Banana 2, it can generate an image
in only a few seconds. So it's way faster while
having very similar quality and understanding.
Here are some additional specs for your reference.
So this can maintain character resemblance of up
to five characters and the fidelity of up to 14
objects in a single prompt. It also has enhanced
instruction following as you can see from some of
my tests. So it's really good at prompt adherence.
You can generate photos in multiple aspect ratios
and resolutions from 512 pixels all the way to 4K
resolution. The really awesome thing about Nano
Banana 2 is they've added four new aspect ratios.
4:1, 8:1, and vice versa. So, this allows you to
create some super long panoramic photos like this,
which aren't possible with earlier versions of
Nano Banana. Now, the awesome thing is they've
released Nano Banana 2 already, and you can use it
for free across Google's platforms right now. So,
here it says if you're using the Gemini app, then
Nano Banana 2 will replace Nano Banana Pro across
the fasting and pro models. In other words, on
the Gemini app, if you click on create image,
it automatically uses the latest NanoBanana
2 already. And apparently in AI mode,
when you're using Google search, you also
have access to Nano Banana 2. For example,
if you're doing a Google search, well, you
can click on this AI mode to basically pull
up Gemini to answer the question for you. And
then over here, you can prompt it further to,
for example, generate an infographic or any other
image from this topic. and it would proceed to use
Nano Banana 2 to generate an image for you.
So, here's what I got. How cool is that? So,
you can get Gemini to do a Google search on a
specific topic first and then get Nano Banana
to create an image on your topic. Really cool.
Everything is seamlessly integrated into this AI
mode in Google search already. Now, in addition,
you can also use this via Google's AI Studio. So,
it's just a studio.google.com, which I'll link
to in the description below. And here is where
you can click on image generation and then use
the new Nano Banana 2. Now here it says you do
need to link a paid API key to access Nano
Banana 2 via this AI studio platform. But
the advantage of this is you can control a lot
more settings like temperature, the aspect ratio,
the resolution. Notice that this is up to 4K.
Plus you can also control the thinking level
as well as turn on grounding with Google search.
So it can actually do a web search for accurate
and relevant information before generating your
image. So those are the main platforms where you
can use the latest Nano Banana 2. Now how good is
this compared to the other leading models? Well,
as you can see from this independent leaderboard
called artificial analysis, Nano Banana 2,
at least the initial ELO score is actually ranked
number one, at least for text to image, well above
GPT Image 1.5 and Nano Banana Pro. And if you
look at the API pricing of this, notice that
this is like two times cheaper than Nano Banana
Pro. So it's way cheaper and faster and on average
you get a better quality generation. Now this is
just the text to image leaderboard. Next, if you
look at image editing, this is where you upload an
image for it to edit further. Then interestingly,
Nano Banana 2 actually ranks below Nano Banana
Pro. And as I showed you from some of my tests,
I also get a similar vibe. It's not as accurate,
especially if you get it sueedit some really
complex stuff with a lot of text or data. Anyways,
that sums up my review of Nano Banana 2. This is
currently one of the best models you can use right
now, and this is way faster and cheaper than the
previous Nano Banana Pro model. It's already out
and free for you to use on the Gemini app. So,
definitely give it a shot, and let me know in the
comments what you think of it. What other cool
stuff were you able to get it to do? Thanks
for watching and if you enjoyed this video,
remember to like and subscribe. And if you've
made it to here, I've got a treat for you. I'm
partnering with Nvidia to give away an RTX 5090
GPU around their GTC 2026 event. With this, you
can easily run AI tools locally on your computer.
Here's how to enter. Simply click the link in the
description to register and attend at least one
GTC 2026 session, which will be on March 16th to
19th. you can attend virtually or in person. Here
are some of my favorites. Jensen Huang's keynote
is an obvious one, but this one on humanoid robots
at scale as well as this one on openw world models
are also on my watch list. Again, make sure you
sign up for GTC using the link in the description
below and then afterwards fill out the form
and you're good to go. It's totally free to